[Musique]
26 voix pour 4 blanc et 2 contres
marie-christine le tarnec est depuis
mardi 15 novembre la nouvelle maire
socialiste de guyancourt l'ancienne élue
en charge notamment des finances succède
à françois de ligne et qu'ils avaient
décidé début octobre de passer le relais
après 14 ans à la tête de la commune ému
au moment de prendre la parole françois
de ligne et restera tout de même
conseiller municipal et communautaire
jusqu'en 2020 mes premiers mots c'est
pour dire que j'ai effectivement
beaucoup d'émotion c'est un passage de
relais
un passage de relais qui se passe bien
comme je l'avais dit je reste dans
l'équipe je resterai aussi conseiller
communautaire mais vous le voyez ma
christine mènera le projet de ville avec
une équipe dynamique
je serai jusqu'à 2020 dans cette équipe
et c'est donc avec beaucoup de sérénité
que je peux participer à a c'est moi qui
sont et ses amis qui sont devant nous
pour l'occasion benoît hamon député ps
et catherine tasca sénatrice socialiste
avait fait le déplacement plus d'une
centaine d'habitants également des
habitants que la nouvelle maire a tenu à
rassurer son mandat sera celui de la
continuité
j'ai été élu sur une liste depuis 2014
donc maintenant je suis maire
effectivement au milieu du mandat mais
j'ai participé à la liste de françois de
ligne et on a été élu pour un mandat
effectivement de 6 ans avec un projet de
ville et je vais respecter les
engagements qui ont été pris devant les
aigles ans pour toi et on va les tenir
l'opposition municipale elle a tenu à
saluer l'engagement de françois de ligne
et durant 14 ans l'élection d'un nouveau
maire signifie également de nouvelles
relations avec la majorité
c'est évident que cette démission doit
aussi nous permettre de relancer de
relancer les échanges de relancer les
discussions avec avec l'exécutif
je proposerai amérique latine le tarnec
peut-être de se voir afin de pouvoir
discuter en effet 2
eh bien deux des quatre années qui
viendront jusqu'en 2020 marie-christine
le tarnec il devra également composer
avec quelques remous au sein de sa
majorité municipale les quatre élus
écologistes n'ont ainsi pas pris part au
vote lors de son élection le retour aux
urnes se fera les 4 et 11 juillet selon
le journal officiel paru samedi
après la décision du conseil
constitutionnel d'annuler l'élection de
jean frédéric poisson il faudra donc
revoter dans la 10e circonscription des
yvelines
le député avait succédé en septembre
dernier à christine boutin
démissionnaire une élection remportée à
cinq voix près face à la candidate
écologiste anny poursinoff
un recours avait été déposé une seule
voix séparent finalement les deux
candidats et la diffusion d'un tract la
veille du scrutin aurait semé la
confusion dans l'esprit des électeurs
selon le conseil constitutionnel
ça n'est jamais simple ce genre de
circonstance dans laquelle nous entrons
ça va nécessiter beaucoup d'efforts
beaucoup de travail mais d'abord j'y
suis prêt deuxièmement j'aime ça et
troisièmement je pense que les électeurs
sont au rendez vous donc voilà les
leçons du premier de la première
élection fin de l'élection précédente en
tout 40 est et ont été tirés maintenant
à nous de faire en sorte que malgré le
mois de juin malgré la coupe du monde de
football malgré le beau temps
malgré le début des vacances c'est bien
de puissions faire une campagne
mobilisatrice et ce à quoi je m'attèle
dès ce matin les verts et europe
écologie soutiennent donc anny
poursinoff dans cette nouvelle campagne
tout comme le mrg le modem et le prg
les discussions sont en cours avec le
parti socialiste
en fait c'est une législative c'est d'un
niveau national donc ça se passe
vraiment directement entre
cécile duflot et martine aubry quoi
c'est plus ça c'est plus moi c'est plus
de mon ressort vraiment pour que
justement avec l'idée qu'on pourrait
faire un troisième tour et s'arrêter au
3e tour avec une victoire sans demander
aux électeurs de revenir faire un
quatrième tôt invité sur le plateau du
direct la semaine dernière jean paul
huchon le président de la région estimé
que la circonscription était prenable si
la gauche était unie
reste à mobiliser des électeurs en
septembre dernier la participation était
seulement de 27 % s'y fait possible dans
la même
[Musique]